it's gorgeous and I got a simple veil to
go with it nothing too insane but just a
little something dad mystery the mystery
is how am I going to walk in it I may
need to borrow Emily's legs well I'll
hemet you're gonna rock this dress I
promise please try it on oh wait what
about the video no that's okay I don't
want anything to detract from the dress
you did good the work here is done what
about the tables you want them to
complement the dress right can I please
do the tables knock yourself out hey hi
Oh go back outside I don't want you see
the brightest spread the open groom
Hanna in the minister or officiator
whatever well I'm styling it so I guess
we'll both be working the party wait
you're gonna be there that's weird why
is it weird because I I didn't invite
any friends or I was trying to be
sensitive sensitive to what we can you
sit at a small wedding with Caleb and
Spencer two feet from the ceremony would
you be comfortable with that I have no
issue with Spencer and Caleb all right
they're great together and we're all
different people now I'm happy for them
this is happy
you